Let's talk a bit about the team projects. As you'll learn later on,
current EHRs are typically deficient, in the ways they collect, and display
clinical data. Although we'll discuss some innovate approaches to data capture,
the visualization challenge is still largely unsolved. The team project is your
opportunity to solve it. Your four person team will develop an approach and
submit it for review. You will then develop a web app based on that approach and
submit it along with a short paper describing your thinking and
what you feel you've achieved. The projects will be evaluated and
graded by the target end user, actual physicians. It will be due at the end of
the course and will account for half your grade. We'll ask each of you for
some background data, so we can assemble four person teams with the right mix of
skills. I'm telling you about the project now and suggesting how you
can begin to do some reading to familiarize yourself with current thinking and
work. Please don't wait until later to start doing this. While this project
may appear to be simple to some of you, I can assure you that it is in fact
quite challenging. Doing it well will require careful thought, analysis, and
design, as well as coding skills. The sooner you start, the better you will do.